not so long ago a luxury hotel break was
about the view great service or simply
enjoying a king-sized bed nowadays
hotels are saying wealthy clients are
after much more this our master suite at
the four seasons in Vail Colorado this 6
bedroom master suite costs $15,000 and
night mom dad children grandma or
grandpa sometimes extended families from
different marriages might come so you
might you might have a the new wife in
the ex-wife actually all here at the
same time staying in the same room the
Four Seasons recently added the tag and
residences to its name one explanation
more clients want a hotel stay closer to
what they know as home across the
Atlantic to central London the recently
opened rosewood is another that claims
to do just that their hope is stunning
their hole is beautiful they have you
know beautiful TVs in their bathrooms
they have you know private stare staff
at their own residence and when they
travel they wish to have the same
services and creature comforts than they
do at home the Rosewood's grand manor
house wing cost nearly 42,000 dollars a
night it boasts a private entrance a
private elevator a library and a butler
service it even has its own postal code
for those who care so does this suggest
a real change in client's demands now
increasingly people are saying look I
have means I've traveled a lot I know
what I want to do I'll let you know when
I want something but otherwise for me
luxury is being left alone in many ways
the hotel industry has never changed
ultimately what the guests once the
guest gets tom gibson bloomberg